he is on the mercedes-benz vans phone
line michael malone how are you coach
uh doing well rich really appreciate you
having me on the show absolutely uh
there's so much so much i want to ask
you about your background and your
history but first things up because uh
stan kroenke owns the nuggets are you
were you mandated to root for the rams
in the super bowl
coach malone yeah
hey i'm a good company man rich okay uh
you know i was definitely rooting for
the rams in the super bowl very happy
uh any of stan and josh's teams arsenal
the rams
avalanche and the nuggets i'm all for
that's right so there's an eye on
michael but you are a team player it's
basically what you're saying on that
front does that mean you also drink
screaming eagle does that is that also
part of this uh equation the cranky
they're ready for the road well i'm just
i i would drink it i'm just waiting to
get my hands on a bottle yeah
come on you know
come on yeah then they're very i mean i
don't know if that fits under the cap
but um
they're very very pricey but i think you
know somebody if you're a red wine
drinker to go and just you know see what
you can
i mean not a case but at least a bottle
or something right yeah yeah i don't
think a bottle's out of the question so
yeah i'll have to talk with stan about
that he's uh
obviously feeling really good yeah the
rams win it the avalanche are rolling uh
we're having a good season considering
all the injuries that we're right we've
had uh so yeah i i think
uh cronkite sports and entertainment uh
things are going well for the family
right now and i'm just happy to be a
part of it michael malone the head coach
of the denver nuggets here on the rich
eisen show um so let's jump into it
right here uh you mentioned the injuries
there are some significant ones that you
have been dealing with and some bold
face names to boot um can you give me an
update on uh jamal murray's status right
now as best you can tell
yeah you know as we all know last april
uh at golden state you know he suffered
a torn acl and it's been a long journey
uh as he's trying to rehab and get back
to playing from that injury rich um and
i i'm so proud of jamal because he has
attacked it he stayed with it um and and
he is
around the team he's able to do some
things in practice not live not contact
obviously
and and hopefully you know we have 21
games remaining uh sometime in march or
april before the playoffs uh there's
definitely a hope that he can rejoin the
team at some point but ultimately i say
this and jamal and i have spoken about
this he'll come back when he's ready
it's not just me the doctor is saying
you're clear to play as we all
understand rehabbing and coming back and
not playing for close to a year it's
also a big mental hurdle and uh and i
want him to feel comfortable and
competent when he makes the decision to
come back when you say mental just
making sure that uh he doesn't think
twice about making a cut or doing
something on the court is that what you
mean by mentally exactly i i think on
one hand you have the hey the injury is
healed he's passed all the
checklist uh parts of coming back and
being cleared to play but there's also
the mental component as you mentioned
okay am i confident enough to go out
here and play an nba game after 11 or 12
months um can i push off that leg can i
jump can i do all the things that used
to be second nature and now you see it
and hear about it from every athlete who
comes back from the acl
when you come back obviously there's
definitely some
um
hesitation and and guys are out there
thinking instead of just playing and
he's gonna have to get over that at some
point but um
he'll he'll tell me when he's ready when
that time comes this year or next uh you
know obviously with a much better team
when jamaal murray plays and puts on a
nugget of uniform nuggets head coach in
his seventh year with the team michael
malone here on the rich eisen show so
what's the scoop with michael porter jr
is there a scoop with him to get him
back yeah no i mean very very similar to
jamal obviously that the big difference
is jamal's been out for close to a year
and michael's been out for three months
uh you know he had his third back
surgery and michael likes them all has a
has really attacked his rehab um getting
healthy is his number one priority
and then he is also you know
participating in parts of practices
parts of shoot-arounds
and it's all the things where there's
really no contact and we're not doing
anything wise they're not cleared for
that just yet but just the slow
integration of both jamal and michael
having them back around the team having
them back on the practice court at times
it's been uplifting for them as well as
all their teammates
and i think we all realize that as well
as we've played this year
winning six in a row being eight and one
in our last nine
we all know that when we have a healthy
michael porter junior and a healthy
jamal murray we're a team that we feel
has a great chance to win a championship
so do you think you're lying in the
weeds is that what you think maybe here
you know i i don't know i just the group
that has played all year has done a
great job of not using the readily
available excuse of well we're injured
this year doesn't matter that hasn't
been our mindset and when guys get back
from injury we'll welcome them back and
integrate them back into the rotation um
but yeah if they're able to come back
and play rich
you know we're a better team there's no
doubt about that well i mean you are
definitely uh you know drawn up some
great plays uh like the the have have
jokic throw it behind his head uh no
luck to someone in the corner wide open
great way to draw that one
up uh coach malone uh i mean i i i saw
that on my phone and i'm like holy crap
i i seriously scrubbed it back and
watched it 10 times in a row what is
that like from from your perspective
when you see that well
obviously you know anytime you have the
opportunity to coach
a great player as a head coach in this
league uh you know it's a privilege it's
an honor and and nicole as a reigning
mvp
uh is making a strong case to be a
repeat mvp
um and his ability
i think the one thing i enjoy most about
coaching nicola um his success his money
his fame he has not changed you know
he's really a selfless leader he's
embarrassed by the attention um
and he that's one thing i love about him
never changing staying true to himself
and being just a humble selfless guy
there's not many superstars like that
and the second thing as you mentioned
what you love about him is
his ability to make everyone around him
better which for me
son of a coach i think is the true
definition of greatness how do you make
everyone around you better and lift
their games up and nikola does that hey
no jamal murray no michael porter it
doesn't matter we have nicola and he's
going to bring the best out of monte
morris will barton jeff greene aaron
gordon and everyone else down the line
um so his unselfish his iq
uh is just a pleasure and uh obviously
he makes me a hell of a lot better of a
coach that's right i described you to
drawing up that play um so
what does he do that in practice i mean
was that the first time you've seen that
no i'd say you know joker and i came in
together we've got seven years together
and you know i saw very early in his
rookie season
that this guy's skill level with all the
charts his ability to rebound and push
the break make no look passes
um it's just something that
i i almost challenged myself never to
take him for granted because he is
um
seven years you've seen him do it so
many times but he still amazes you with
the passing the play making the ability
to hit clutch shots
uh the the ability to grow as a leader
and to learn to be more vocal and to be
more comfortable being more vocal he's
like he hasn't reached his feelings he's
still getting better in other areas and
that's the thing i love about him he's
not satisfied michael malone denver
nuggets head coach here on the rich
eisen show
so i you mentioned you're the son of a
coach brendan is your dad i'm 52 i think
you're 50 right you're just a couple
years younger than me and i remember um
as a new york kid being on the campus of
the university of michigan as the bad
boys were beginning to blossom
man did i hate their guts i absolutely
hated their guts to be very honest with
you were you like a teenager with a
front row seat during practice watching
those guys oh man you know i've been
really privileged rich you know
obviously my father started out as a
high school coach in new york city pound
memorial and worked his way into the nba
and
uh you know to be
i'm in high school he used to go to the
new york knick games with pat ewing and
being able to shoot around madison
square garden as a young kid from queens
and long island was like a dream and
then go then he goes to detroit and the
bad boys and the back-to-back
championships and being around
isaiah thomas joe dumas vinnie johnson
john sally
i was uh i was really fortunate to grow
grow up as a son of a coach
and i just have great memories of
driving around when he's an assistant
coach at syracuse and going to games in
new york city and recruiting helping
recruit pearl washington and and other
guys that he would be
watching and recruiting so i have so
many stories and just really blessed to
have that experience as a son of a coach
and i believe that's really helped me
become the coach that i am today was
that bernard king too was king bernard
around at that time
that was after obviously uh you know
ernie and bernie down to tennessee ernie
gruntfeld and bernard king right uh i
remember i mean
billy donovan mark jackson kenny smith
dwayne washington has so many players in
the new york city area that
um i just would be
walking around with my father watching
these games and uh
i loved it and so uh what presents did
chuck daley have in your life yeah i
mean you know obviously chuck daley one
of the greatest coaches in nba history
and and just whether it was hubby brown
with the knicks whether it was a chuck
daley um whether it's you know jeff and
stan van gundy all guys that my father
worked for yeah um but again it wasn't
just the players but as an aspiring
coach myself
you know just to be a fly in the wall
to to
learn to pick things up to see how they
coach and every coach is different you
know you have a guy in chuck daley who
um looked apart
one of the best dress coaches in nba
history and then he had other guys you
know who just you know grinded out
coaches who were you know their work
ethic is legendary so
i i think you can learn and take
something from everybody along the way
and that's what i try to do from my
father but even when i was an assistant
for many years in the league learning
from the guys that i work for
what about do you got a good story from
like us let's just throw out the pistons
days that mchorn come up to you did
lambeau haze you did anything happen uh
rodman anything from the bad boy days
that you might remember
anybody i just remember like
you know being around those teams and
this is like
you know the bad boys and women in
chicago just having battle and obviously
chicago had to get through detroit for
their ascension and to go on their
historic run that they wind up going on
with michael jordan and scottie pip and
phil jackson uh but i just remember
being at practices and and listening to
joe dumas like talking about you know
how hard it was to guard a guy like
michael jordan um and
he would come down on the break and he'd
literally put the ball on his hand and
he could just go wherever he wanted
and just
i mean
i never took it for granted you know
here i am a young kid being around nba
players nba champions
and and just they always treated me well
and it was always a pleasure to be
around those teams whether it was a
knicks team a piston team my father's
first head coaching job in toronto
whatever it was
i always took a lot of joy in terms of
seeing my father and being around those
teams i i got to be honest i i have
just again such an affinity for those
times and and it's just like any
generation right my generation's better
than the current generation but
is the game better now
or or because you know obviously it's a
more three-point centric game
nobody's put on their ass as much as
those back in the day i mean what what's
your philosophy on all that being a head
coach in this current day and age and
seeing what used to be in this league
well yeah it's funny i speak to my
father about it all the time
and he's obviously old school he was in
the league for a long time
and like he has a hard time watching the
nba game today because of as you
mentioned you know all the three-point
shooting and and let's be honest the
game has changed as you mentioned that
guy's getting put on their ass you've
talked about the bad boys i go back to
the new york knicks with charles oakley
and patrick ewing and those guys
the game has changed and the nba wanted
the game to change they wanted to clean
it up they wanted to make it more fan
friendly and that is always what that
means is
they've tried to make it more scoring
because scoring makes more fans watch
and more entertainment and that's what
it's all about but i like the the old
days i like the
physicality no layups not dirty not
trying to hurt anybody but you know
making people feel you out there and you
know i i think there's some teams that
play like that now but the game has
definitely changed and the reality is
rich the game is always changing it's
constantly changing it's constantly
evolving and you have to be willing to
change with it
michael malone few more minutes left
with the denver nuggets head coach here
on the rich eisen show okay so you said
you you you you put your old school
credentials on the table
you called chuck daley one of the best
dressed head coaches of all time i have
to be honest with you i'm gonna be
straight up i'm very disappointed that
nba head coaches are dressing like
they're going to the gym for practice
and you know again it's not my dry
cleaning bill you know it's not my it's
not my you know uh it's not my bill to
go you know uh shopping but what what's
the deal what what happened what
happened yeah you know
it's funny well i'm gonna go on record
saying i hope it never goes back
i know there are people like yourself a
lot of people say
nba headquarters look like they're you
know middle school gym teachers right
now
i love it i love it when you go on a
14-day seven-game road trip
you're not packing seven suits shirts
ties dress shoes belts coordinating all
that you're just packing a pair of um
really comfortable pants shoes and a
quarter zip pull over from mikey and uh
that's it it all happened when we went
to the bubble right and there were no
fan and there were no fans and the idea
was well there's no fans here what the
hell are we dressing up for and if uh
the nba coaches
have overwhelmingly voted to continue to
have this as long as the nba is going to
allow it because i think
uh you know you're out there you're
coaching you're sweating and it's a lot
easier to do your job comfortably as
opposed to looking like a pat riley or
chuck bailey dressed to deny so is there
anybody out there that's pushing for the
suit to come back anybody oh yeah
there's definitely some coaches that are
kind of you know whether it's old school
mentality that they they
like the fact that we're dressing up and
we're not a gym teacher and you're
putting your suit and tie on you're
working the part
but let's be honest yeah you had to
chuck daily but then you also had guys
like don nelson wearing the fish ties
so
you know even back in the day you had
some coaches that should be you know i'm
gonna dress and i'm gonna take pride in
my dressing right and you had other
coaches saying listen i'll i'll put a
jacket under tie on but i'm not worried
about how it looks i'm worried about
coaching my team
and i think that's what a lot of coaches
now feel is hey i'm not a banker i'm not
a lawyer i'm a coach let me go out there
and be comfortable
hey major league baseball they wear the
uniform i know right i know maybe we
should wear the uniform yeah just like
yeah like like a jackie moon movie or
something you just show up in your
shorts you know but we're you know we so
again i'm fascinated by this and and
then uh then i'll let you go i promise
you so uh because
if a head coach just showed up okay
let's just say um
later on this year
quinn snyder just shows up in a full
suit and tie because we think he's the
guy that really is desperate to get the
suits back on to be very honest with you
coach like would this be a problem if
another head coach just showed up in a
suit and didn't tell anybody and just
started wearing it would that be an
issue do you think it would not be an
issue for me and i actually have a story
about that uh i think it was the end of
last season
and we were getting ready to play
portland uh and terry stops who was her
head coach at the time
uh have a great relationship terry great
coach she should be back in the nba but
he sends me a text and says hey listen
you know for our game we're gonna wear
uh suits uh suits and ties are you okay
with that
and i said hey jerry knock yourself out
i said i'm not wearing a suit and tie
but if you guys want to wear a suit and
tie and impress your home fans have at
it okay they did they they all came out
with suits and ties on and uh they
looked great but you know we were over
there looking uh looking really
comfortable
so he gave you the professional courtesy
at least right like he didn't want to
show you
okay he didn't didn't surprise us he
gave us the courtesy i actually think he
was hoping that we'd wear it but we had
already left denver on a three-game road
trip and i said we didn't pack any suits
and even if we had time we wouldn't pack
suits anyway
i am fascinated by this all right so
last one for you what would it mean to
to bring a uh the larry o'brien trophy
to denver what would that mean for you
that would mean uh that would mean so
much you know you talked about stan
kroenke earlier in the show and
i've gotten to know stan and josh
terrific ownership group very fortunate
that they continue to believe in me but
they've won a stanley cup they've won an
nfl and they love basketball so i first
and foremost i mean this uh it would
mean a lot to the cranky family because
that's one thing that they're still
uh trying to attain it would mean a lot
for our staff our players the
organization but more importantly would
mean a lot to this city i've been here
seven years our fans
uh have been phenomenal a big part of
our ascension in the western conference
so to bring home a world championship to
this city to our fans uh would be an
honor and a privilege and uh and i think
we'd all be very very proud to be a part
of that so that is what drives us every
day rich that is our goal
um and hopefully
in the next few years we're able to make
that goal a reality
well thanks for the time coach this has
been a blast i hope it's the first of
many other times that you come on send
my best to your dad uh i'm again a die
hard knick fan from those days anthony
mason's another name that um that i
loved in terms of putting people on
their ass we had oakley here the other
day he's selling a book and
those are my days man those were my
times and i i loved them so thank you
dad although the bad boy stuff really
pissed me off it's all good
it's all good i'll let him know that the
nick days were okay not so much for
detroit and uh richard was really good
to be on with you i look forward to
doing it again
anytime i can talk to somebody from
staten island yes that's right i'm from
the rock that's where i'm from that's
where i'm from thanks for the call
really appreciate coach yeah thank you
yeah there you go that's uh michael
malone coach michael malone of the
denver nuggets what a pleasure that was
great
what a pleasure hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here